the economy is faltering crime is on the
rise education is in the doldrums we
can't afford eggs we can't afford a
whole host of goods and what is our
president focusing on well he's focusing
on the important issues like giving
ukrainians pensions and to deliver much
needed humanitarian assistance as well
as food water medicine shelter and other
Aid to ukrainians displaced by Russians
war and provide aid for those seeking
refuge in other countries from Ukraine
and it's also going to help schools and
hospitals open
it's going to allow pensions and social
support to be paid to the Ukrainian
people so they have something something
in their pocket it's really important
those ukrainians might not have
something in their pockets they might be
struggling to go out and buy the really
fancy eggs you selfish Americans you
don't want to send them another
100 billion dollars